while the age of empires progressed all
forms of life ranging from these
spacefaring forces to single-celled
organisms all existed as but one version
of themselves within our universe beyond
this resided the multiverse a mass of
interweaving of realities while some of
these universes were identical to our
own others differed greatly if the
legends of old are to be believed at the
beginning of all things before the
formation of the first universe there
existed that one above all as the
supreme creator as well as nemesis
possessing control of our space-time the
sole reality the mind and pure power as
the sole entity in existence nemesis
fell into a state of loneliness and
despair electing to end its own life
dispersing its energies and their
entirety
nemesis gave birth to the multiverse
planting within each universe six
singular gems containing a portion of
its power travelling back our universe
as the empires of various races grew and
were replaced the universe was being
explored by the Phoenix force unlike the
traditional cosmic entities of eternity
infinity Galactus and others the Phoenix
force did not contain different
iterations of itself across the
multiverse instead despite the existence
of infinite universes within the
multiverse there existed only one
Phoenix force representing the total sum
of all future life born through the
multiverse itself the Phoenix force
existed with immense power serving as a
nexus for all psychic energy that has
ever currently does or will ever exist
initially existing as a formless mass of
energy while we don't know what the
Phoenix was doing in the early days of
the universe what we do know is that in
a universe wildly different from our own
a being named nekron had come to
understand the power of the Phoenix
operating is that universes sorcerer
supreme
nekron had taken advantage of the
Phoenix forces lack of experience in
dealing with deception manipulating the
Phoenix into building pillars across the
multiverse that Crom intended to
converge all realities into a
singularity forcing a collapse of the
multiverse and absorbing the energies
emitted by its death transforming him
into a god
however the schemes of nekron we
discovered by his students and while he
was defeated the Phoenix went forward
operating largely within our universe
and seeking to better understand the
minds of mortal creatures with the
threat of neck kromm reaching the ears
of almost all beings across the
multiverse an individual of unknown
origin named Merlin had come to the
conclusion that the various realities of
the multiverse needed a means of
observation and protection against such
a threat and finding himself to a pocket
dimension outside of all space and time
known as Otherworld
we're lynn said about creating the
omniversal development court a governing
body designed to observe the development
of each universe within the multiverse
and ensure their safety
traveling back to our universe while the
planet zenn-la
remained in isolation from the various
empires and forms of life their position
in the cosmos was about to radically
change on the far side of reality
Galactus continued his role as the
devourer of worlds and found that his
hunger was growing traversing the cosmos
and coming upon zenn-la as one of the
many worlds rich in life supporting
energy Galactus intended to consumes in
law however at the behest of one of its
citizenry his in-laws execution estate
born to the brilliant scientist Geron
who encouraged his son to pursue
knowledge advancement and achievement
unlike everybody else sons in law who
saw Galactus coming as they're
guaranteed end knowing rad saw hope
petitioning Zin law Science Council to
grant him a vessel Norrin Radd struck a
pact with Galactus with the devourer of
worlds becoming increasingly weaker due
to having to search at his own
sustenance
if Galactus speared zenn-la no one rad
would abandon his home and service
Galactus is Herald traveling the
universe in search of suitable planets
agreeing to these terms
Norrin Radd was transformed into the
Silver Surfer who in turn would locate
planets capable of satiating the
lattices hunger but lacking sentient
life but the Silver Surfer serving his
purpose back in our solar system the
destiny of Thanos was beginning as the
son of a Lars an eternal from Earth
Thanos was at his core human but with
both Eternals and deviance stemming from
the human gene unlike those around him
on Titan Thanos was born with both
eternal and deviant genes making him a
mutant among his own race however unlike
a lars who considered anos a worthy
successor to the eternal throne Thanos
his mother sweet son saw him as the
death of them all
initially trying to kill her son on
birth while sweets on was stopped by a
Lars her claims of impending doom at the
hands of Thanos led to her incarceration
within a mental institution
spending his childhood as a pacifist
Thanos kept largely to himself playing
only with his brother arose however
after encountering a fellow student her
manipulations began to see the views of
Thanos shifting from non-aggression to
obsession with nihilism and death
encouraged by his family to develop
friends the young Thanos was tricked
into visiting a cave alongside several
other students experiencing a cave-in
Thanos was forced to bear witness as his
friends were consumed by lizards forced
to return to a life of isolation the
young girl persuaded Thanos to drop his
pacifist nature returning to the cave
and killing the lizards following this
and had to behest of the young girl
Thanos began kidnapping various
creatures from around his city
initiating a series of grisly
experiments that kill them but enable
Thanos to better understand the natural
physiology of organisms and his search
to understand why he was physically
different from everyone else continuing
along this path by his teenage years and
after expanding his experiments to his
own race Thanos had murdered 17
individuals many of whom were his own
classmates failing to find his answers
the more Thanos engaged in murder the
more his focus shifted from research to
desire after which he abandoned Titan
and took to exploring the Stars while
the path of Thanos would lead him
inexorably towards his fate back on
earth the Elder Gods refused to be
forgotten after spending 3 billion years
in isolation a handful of Elder Gods
sought to use mankind as a means to
ensure their legacy coming together in
the form of the octet since the Elder
Gods would tune both AG econ for ala sit
iraq kraken ragged or and vault r came
together for a test to determine the
strongest member among them creating an
artifact of their own design those
humans who continue to worship the Elder
Gods built tombs housing these artifacts
sealing the tombs and sacrificing their
lives these items would remain until one
was touched by human hands after which
humanity would be drawn to the remaining
7 and those that acquired them would
lead humanity in a war against itself
while time would see the passing of 4000
years before this prophecy would be
fulfilled with the existence of these
artifacts remaining hidden the ancient
mutant apocalypse was beginning his
reign following his escape from the
confines of Egypt of hakka lafe's went
forward throughout the world pitting
various civilizations against one
another as a means to eliminate the weak
from the strong
during this time and in the 15th century
unsub on or had fancied himself a
warlord building an army of the
strongest fighters from those
civilizations he had conquered and
christening them the riders of the dark
using the riders to conquer more
territories the life events of on or in
the future of the world was changed
irrevocably with the arrival of Nathan
de spring hailing from 4,500 years in
the future cable from the time of his
adolescence knew only of a world ruled
by apocalypse imposing his philosophy of
social Darwinism under the rule of
apocalypse earth had become a cruel and
brutal place or the weak were eliminated
to make way for the strong intending to
keep his future from coming into
fruition cable travelled into the past
under the guise of the traveler
intending to end apocalypse before he
could seize power however during in
Subodh newest travels he had encountered
a ship left behind by the Celestials
during their experiments on early man
unable to access its technology during
his original encounter apocalypse
greeted cable as an enemy with the two
doing battle against one another while
cable proved himself the victor his
cybernetic blood merged with apocalypse
allowing him to communicate with the
ship
striking a patch with one of the
Celestials apocalypse was granted use of
their technology and went forward with a
host of new powers hell-bent on world
domination bearing witness to the fruits
of his labor cable was forced to come to
recognize that he himself was the being
responsible for engineering apocalypses
rise to power
the most important thing that I always
tried to do was concentrate on the
characters even before I would dream up
the story I would try to think who are
the characters what are their
personalities what type of people are
they and why should a reader care about
them why should a real reader be
interested in them to me the same thing
holds for movies television you've got
to have characters that the audience the
viewer the reader cares about once you
do that making up stories is easy the
serious themes that I would occasionally
inject were for another reason I began
to realize judging by the fan mail that
we received I began to realize that our
books had quite an influence on the
readers and I kind of took that
seriously I felt if these people are
reading my words and the words of the
other writers working for Marvel I felt
we've got to be careful and we've got to
make sure that we're not giving them the
wrong messages